ان تامر القصف على كياذ من جديد اخيرا
معلومات المتوفره بشان ما اسفر عنها عنه
هذا القص
نعم حسن المعلومات شحيحه حتى هذه هي
اللحظه نحن نستق هي الاخبار تحديدا من
عمده كياب ومن الاداره العسكريه والمدنيه
في العاصمه عمده كيا في اخر تحديث له قبل
دقيقه من الان قال بان القصف الروسي الذي
جرى بصواريخ همم اسفره عن مقتل مدني
واصابه سبعه اخرين وقال بان احد هؤلاء
المصابين يعاني حاله حرجه القصف همم جرى
في عدد من المناطق المدنيه هنا في قلب
العاصمه كياب بالاضافه بالاضافه الى ضواحي
همم العاصمه وهمم شرق العاصمه شرق العاصمه
الذي كانت تعرض لقصف اول من امس والسيدفت
فيه مناطق مدنيه
ورصدنا دمارا كبيرا في عدد من المنازل
وكان هنالك عدد من الجرح ايضا هذا الذي
جرى اول من امس يوم امس ايضا تعرضت
العاصمه لقصف بطائرات مسيره لا تاتي
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها تمكنت من
اسقاط كامل هذه الطائرات والحديث كان عن
تسعه من الطائرات من نوع شاهد
واليوم حتى هذه اللحظه الحديث عن هجوم
صاروخي فقط حتى هذه اللحظه وفقا لعمده
العاصمه ويقول بان القصف الذي تعرضت له
العاصمه استهدف مناطق مدنيه نحن الان في
طريقنا في الحقيقه الى احد المواقع التي
تم اعلامنا بها والتي تعرضت للقصف واحد
ايضا من الفنادق الكبيره والرئيسيه هنا في
العاصمه تعرض لقصف كبير وشاهدنا مقطع عن
مصورا بتتوا الاداره العسكريه هنا في كيف
ذلك الفندق وكانت الاضرار فادحه وبالغه في
همم الحقيقه وهذا القصف لم يستهدف فقط
كلاب وانما عدد كبير من المقاطعات لاسيه
الجنوب وتقول الادارات العسكريه في هذه
الاثناء تحديدا في اوديستا وفي ميكولايب
وفي خير سون وفي الباروديا بان الدفاعات
الجويه كانت تعمل طيله الدقائق الماضيه
وانها تمكنت من اسقاط عدد من الصواريخ
واستطيع القول وانقل هنا تحديدا على لسان
عمده نيكولايف جنوبيه البلاد بان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت هنالك عدد من الصواريخ لكن
هنالك انفجارات ايضا
استهدفت عددا من المباني السكنيه
فيميكولاي وفي حتى هذه اللحظه نحن قبل اقل
من ساعه من الان كنا نستمع الى صوت او
اصوات اصوات مكثفه للدفاعات الجويه هنا في
قلب العاصمه كياب وكنا نشاهد اعمده الدخان
في الحقيقه حسن بالعين المجرده اعمده
الدخان الناتجه عن الدفاعات الجويه التي
كانت تضرب صواريخا روسيه في قلبها العاصمه
واستطيع القول ايضا بان واحده من اهم
المناطق التي انطلقت فيها الدفاعات الجويه
في قلب العاصمه هي منطقه القصر الرئاسي
منطقه القصر الرئاسي التي همم الذي فيه
الرئيس اوزنسكي الدفاعات الجويه تعمل من
فتره لاخرى وخلال الساعه الماضيه كانت ال-
ال- الاكثر يعني كثافه من ناحيه اطلاق
الدفاعات الجويه هنا في كياب طيله اليومين
الماضيين عندما تعرضت العاصمه للقصف كانت
السلطات تقول بان الاضرار تركزت بدرجه
رئيسيه على البنيه التحتيه وهو ما ادى الى
انقطاعات كبيره وهائله في الكهرباء حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تعلن السلطات عن اي اضرار
اخرى سواء الاضرار في المناطق المدنيه
ننتظر
اتباعا ماسه تعلوه الاداره العسكريه هنا
في العاصمه شكرا